foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
now
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
all right good morning suppliers 30
seconds before we start the last round
30 seconds
for the first morning moves 36 uh 30
minutes of the game with a 30 second
increment starting from move one
um in terms of the playoffs uh Group B
Gran racist Alex Linderman who won Group
B so
uh so it could be even though there's no
playoffs group a if there is a playoff
playoffs will start at five o'clock for
those who are type of first and if there
is a playoff in this for everybody
um if they're in the playoff appetizers
it will start at six o'clock if there is
no point I'll still start at 5 30. so
um the closing ceremony dinner will be a
king size Diner which is right in front
of the Chesapeake so
um
otherwise
um thank you guys for coming to the ball
plastic
um hope you guys have it before you say
um thanks to my interview order my
camera is all over there Mike
what's up everybody so and otherwise
thanks again and uh number one it is one
o'clock 30 11 o'clock 11 o'clock uh good
luck can I start my spot
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to the final
round we're on day nine here of the Fall
chess classic uh everything is going to
be decided already everything in the B
group has been decided but there's still
everything to play for in the a group my
name is Jonathan tronson I'm very happy
to be sitting right next to Grand Master
Miro are going to be going through it so
is there anything that really has your
attention for this very last well the a
group of course has four contenders well
well those guys who mathematically can
win right absolutely for some it's more
likely than for the others right none of
them
playing against each other so they
basically they are splitting the pairing
and all have the white pieces here yeah
we'll get it we'll get everything can
possibly happen here and let's get to
know standings in group a so we can see
exactly what we're talking about in the
a group at the very top we have Yu Yang
Yi he's coming in with five and a half
points he's a half Point ahead of
everybody but right below him there's a
lot of people that could potentially
catch him a half Point behind that Five
Points we have visited we have Von
Nguyen and below that even Hans Neiman
has a technical mathematical shot yeah
uh at winning this tournament uh under
that we have the rest of our competitors
Gregory o'para and Nigeria ebsov
aeromacobian ilionis Nick Nicholas
theodoro and Surya Ganguly now we know
who the champ is in Group B it's Al Alex
Slenderman he has already clinched he
clinched with a day to go which is
always a very nice thing right so there
will be there will be no playoffs in
group b but there will be a huge fight
for the second place
[Music]
because if we look at the standings of
Group B you might pay attention that we
have I don't even know like five people
yeah died for the second run at sadwani
then he's got rich Christopher you
gergelicantor and tigran harrogenian all
of those tied for the second and even
Christian shirella in case like all the
guys above him finishing the throw he
has a mathematical chest of such as yeah
clinching into this thigh
wonderful and uh with that let's
actually get to know our tournament a
little bit better with our tournament
format this is two 10 player round
Robins we got an A group and a b group
it's 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
in 30 minutes after that for the rest of
the game and as always there is a 30
second increments all throughout now if
there is a playoff today here is exactly
what's going to happen this would be in
the a group only they would play two
games in a rapid match you'll be game in
10 minutes with a two second delay not
an increment but a delay and if that
ends up in a tie we will then have an
Armageddon match to decide at all white
would have five minutes black would have
four minutes and draw odds now with that
again just want to thank everybody
that's kind of been with us whether this
is your first day here or you've been
with us for every single round thank you
we're watching you guys we are live on
Twitch we are Live on YouTube and as
always we invite you to join the
conversation by using the hashtag fall
chess classic or watching all of the
games live on uschess champs.com uh and
with all of that I want to take a look
now at at the pairings for group okay
this is where everything is going to be
decided today because we got nijan absof
going up against Nicholas theodoro and
then one potential person the least
likely perhaps to mathematically be able
to win yeah
as you could guess from the standings
Hans not only he wins needs to win his
game but he needs like require a lot of
unions to lose and yeah none of those
people on four and a half wins but yeah
but still mathematically possible don't
get your hopes up if that is something
that we'll be looking at as well another
key matchup to keep our eye on is the
game between nguin and how Cobian
okobian only a half Point behind our
leaders so if he can win and maybe he
gets a draw or whatever maybe something
exciting could happen there as uh as
well sorry win is
both then we have oh well pretty much in
the same situation we did Gujarati
against Ilya niznik did it also have a
point behind you young yes if will it
wins and once again very conveniently
all the contenders having the white
pieces so why not if he wins he Yankee
ends up not winning once again here we
go it's a tie and Yu yangi is the only
man who has his fate
and that's perhaps the game we start
yeah let's definitely go ahead and
discover his way here because if he wins
again he does win the entire section so
uh let's see what is going on here he
has the white pieces here against
Gregory oporah yeah well it does look
very attractive for him what I want to
say so a pair of Bishops and like yeah
that's one first thing to notice and I
also I just realized how kind of tied
down uh black pieces are it's white to
move and oh well and he just played
Queen F5 so we witnessed this queen of
fine whip okay so that's the pin I can
see and that's the other one and you
know the f7s targeted the knights very
like the pawn is not hanging now right
black still has enough recaptures on E5
but uh like putting a lot of pressure on
the E file yeah like you try to kind of
check manually one but one by one by one
which piece can actually move and it's
not too many it's not too many like you
moved an ID five wins right the big one
F6 yeah like once again a rook just went
to E7 so perhaps it'd be a move with the
other rook and white has like a ton of
very useful moves like maybe uh once
again doubling the Rooks on the E file
I'm afraid I'm afraid the pouring e is
in quite a bit of trouble wow so that
could be huge news for our tournament if
this is ending up very well for you Yang
Yi can we actually see how this whole
game even started yeah let's just let's
just quickly check uh what has happened
here so it is uh Royal Lopez and that's
you know
nowadays even when black attempts to
play the Berlin it feels like you know
fresh air compared to this Italian
that's right so D3 nevertheless okay and
black girls for well kind of
not the most popular follow-up with D7
D6 so usually of course Bishop C5 is the
main move here but D6 nothing wrong with
D6 and once again some quite strong
players played it uh Castle Bishop E7
Rook to E1 castles do you already even
at this opening stage have kind of the
sense that maybe Yu Yang Yi is trying to
just get a position or he might be able
to win like maybe he's trying to avoid a
playoff and just get a position where
you don't have to take chances but if
you get an opportunity maybe you'll yeah
well for it you know this one it doesn't
look like Ultra aggressive so basically
I just go all in and he's not in the
position to go all these because he's
got something to lose like a draw
guarantees him a tie for the first
absolutely that's not when not the game
where you play the Queen's King's Gambit
or something sure of course right and
this lower approach with D3 it actually
does keep like a lot of pieces on the
board he wants to play for a long time
yeah
basically we are talking the same the
same rui Lopez I'd say with
kind of you know
Tempo Tempo down for white on many
occasions because he will play default
you know later
but very often strangely enough white
would save on this move or that moves I
say it's not like straight up the same
position you would have them down so
well
anyway so H3 played too early perhaps
black starts this bishop f8 business
because yeah white girls Bishop G5
Bishop H1 this pin is quite annoying for
now B5 Bishop to B3 Knight A5 Bishop C2
C5 said black arrange his pieces in a
way he would in the what's it called
chigorian variation right
of the real Lopez A4 B4 traded here
Knight D2 Bishop E7 and this is like we
were talking about white being a Tempo
down but how about black playing Bishop
f8 is then returning to E7 right Bishop
to G3 Knight D7 D4 and this already
feels like a very pleasant position for
white
uh black lacks like real counter Play
Bishop B7 Knight A5 Queen A5 and another
Knight is going via D2 to like C4 or B3
so in case of ed4 for instance Knight C4
attacks the queen then jumps to D6 it's
it's a better position already Rook C8
he stops IT white insists on like heavy
Knight C4 map and black girls for this
breakthrough with D5 and it might be
that yeah the position already not fun
for black right but D5
seems like it only speeds up
stuff so Queen to G4 and C to d8 e D5 e
Bishop D5 Knight C4 and nevertheless
hands up capturing on C4 so white gets
this light coefficient Rook E7 Queen F5
B3 that's that's what Opera implies
and it just does have the sense that
like it's just a little bit more tied up
than black in this position so this
could be huge do you think this is
enough to start thinking that you could
actually win this game avoiding a
playoff or if you feel it's just a small
thing yes I think white is like not just
better but much better here and I mean
first of all can't you can't you just
take this guy it's a B3 yeah I mean I
understand Black's motivation to play B3
because he still can't find like um you
know
a proper move he has to defend the E5
poll and white otherwise would have
played Victory himself just like well
maybe not creating immediate threats but
just like
kind of brushing up the position so
everything is everything is safe and
sound so B3 at least kind of tried to
destabilize a little
and now the bishop C4 is hanging in some
lines like say white can't really go F4
which otherwise wouldn't be wouldn't be
bad because it's a pin over the fifth
rank right and why just basically it's
pretty funny that basically threatens to
capture only five yeah but but then
Queen B4 happens and yeah attacks the
bishop and through this bishop attacks
the D4 pawns F4 is not yet a move but
the idea is around
all right
okay so I would say it's a good chance
that you Yankee
well just win it move 27 for the move 28
for white to play upwarring down to 15
minutes and not the time trouble yet but
in this kind of you know uh complex and
also unpleasant positions One turns to
spend a lot of time yes of course that's
very good huge implications if you're
the fans of playoffs might be a little
disappointed to know this but big fans
of Yu Yang Yi might be excited that he
might be on the verge of taking the a
group here of the Fall chess classic we
want to take a look now at some of the
other games
hams hams
how is Hans doing today Hans ease up a
pawn yeah so yesterday he broke his
seven game drawing streak with his first
win of the tournament how's he doing
today uh so today that's the position he
has but so just quickly we'll click
through yeah we'll click through the key
moments a bishop to be five Knight F6
another attempt to play the Berlin from
Surya Ganguly d2d3 and kind of
confirming on this one right now but
this is D3 and Bishop C5 right so Bishop
C6 dc6 Knight to D2 I think we've seen
it right Bishop E6 castles Queen D6 B3
A5 A3 to be honest the set of moves Hans
played looks pretty random
but yeah Knight to D7 my GPS where they
put the bishop on B2 and it is like yeah
it's a little bit weird but 84 captures
on E6 and what's what's to be honest
like really amazing
uh perhaps he lost this ah he can't play
before because to me it looks like so
natural you played before and then you
continue developing but I'm guessing
yeah strangely enough I'm just I'm just
thinking how does do you untie this
thing yeah okay nothing is hanging by
the way yeah but how will you like the
night's not moving yeah yeah you know
that kind of develop the bishop you have
to move the Knight so I'm not sure I
mean and even white kind of even play C4
and claim that Queen is almost trapped
but almost doesn't yeah yeah it's very
interesting that'd be that'd be a very
interesting position to follow anyway
Hans just played Bishop B2 we've traded
here B B4 Queen C2 and he ended up
winning a porn strangely okay Bishop
here C5 yeah that was perhaps Black's
choice to sacrifice the pawn I'm not
sure why exactly he went for it Queen to
C6 Bishop E3 B6 so there is this pain
and black does win
a piece back but he is down a Pawn Yeah
Bishop before trades here Rook A7 Rook
D1 F6 King F1 C5 so at least uh black is
getting this rook and game four Rooks
and here
I'd say still some chances for hands
okay check over here King F7 H5 H6 not a
big fan of H6 creating some holes
potentially
F4 sure Rook A2 Rook D2
yeah that's one of those end games where
you know where white is not that unhappy
to even trade a pair of drugs
if white is trying to win and I don't
know why it's intentions but you're a
pawn up yeah do you want do you want two
Rooks on the board or just one yes
originally I thought you want to
originally I thought you want to uh so
that as a general rule too is yeah Dewey
easier more than one yeah no it's just
that rookan games tend to have those
like a draw Tendencies whatever it's
called and one Pawn on say One Wing
usually is not enough right to right
forward and then uh your chances
kind of uh grow with the number of Pawns
on it but it's a one one Pawn let's say
you have the H Pawn or the g-pawn it's
just a dead draw right assuming that the
pawn is not promoting automatically then
two versus one it's like 99 cases draw
the three versus two is three streakier
four versus three sometimes winning and
so on and so on so I would expect this
one uh like if mathematically played
correctly white has well quite a decent
chance of converting maybe 50 trade who
knows uh but yeah but since he's gotten
you know uh this H5 H6 inclusion in I
think we could say that some new
information appeared because he has I
say Rooks are traded and black probably
doesn't want to get something like this
because then after F5 the pawns uh
immobilized and he yeah basically you
just move the Deep on forward so he
doesn't want to trade and yeah well some
scenario were white trades goes D4 later
on I mean he will be able to just trust
me he will be able to go before yeah and
I mean
picture this thing like white has the E
past pawn and the other pawns remaining
are those G7 H6 versus H5 G4 probably
why it's going to play G4 and this is
known to be a winning position so like
because black is kind of has so little
space the e-pawn moves at once again
it's a clumsy explanation probably
you've you've lost me somewhere on the
way right a bunch of moves on the board
moves yeah fake moves yeah fake myth
just yeah I mean just structure that
you're talking about just to show yeah I
mean I can do it is all the moves so
I'll I'll just yeah like black will
allow some stuff yeah obviously sure
should have prevented rupee three yeah
but what I'm talking about so that
something like that and white can do it
kind of an inaccurate manner not one day
anything in the way right and basically
white is opting for some position like
this so if we get to like E6 yeah and
like since it that close to the
promotion Square white will be winning
like penetrating with the King to G6 you
move it one file or what's that
horizontal line down so it's G7 becomes
G6 yeah H6 becomes H5 of its own so on
it's a true this one it's known to be
winning okay if nothing has changed
since I've opened the End Game book last
time so you see there's a chance yeah
there is there is quite a serious chance
and excited black decided not to trade
to keep more pieces so he is arguing
that yeah okay I have two Rooks so maybe
it won't be that easy for you to push
push the Deep on but yeah I believe
France is yeah he has a shot at least he
has a shot at winning this one all right
so if black is just going to keep both
the Rooks on the board
I guess what's the how do you try to win
this yeah
uh that's a that's not as easy well
actually that's a good question I mean
this is how do you
how do you maybe like made a very good
yeah yeah maybe he's he's very clever
right with one drug say these Rooks are
not here right then yeah then you can
speculate that I'll go D4 at some point
yeah maybe yeah maybe that's that's just
a very clever very clever defensive
setup but yeah it's up to hunt we'll see
all right so yeah we'll be keeping our
eyes on this one seeing if on somehow
finds a way to convert an extra pawn and
we do have a lot of action going on in
the B group so uh this tournament has
been decided but they are playing lots
of exciting games today so let's go
ahead and see the standings for the B
group yeah proud and that's the pairings
right sorry the pairings for the B group
today are Brandon Jacobson versus Tigard
hartunian Armin melchion versus
Christopher you akshat Chandra versus
ronak sadwani Ganguly cantar versus
Dennis contract and tournament winner
Alex Linderman is going up against our
own Christian gorilla so why don't we
start there and see what's going on
because as that very distant outside
chance of second place somehow uh and
let's see if it's even possible what's
going on all right so that's that's the
position they currently have move 42 so
they've both passed the time control
and the question is a pawn up
but I don't think you can make much out
of it
Pawn up two Bishops but the structure is
you know it's very hard to set those
Pawns in motion right and white pretty
much just
weights here and that's what he had been
doing for like last few last few moves
interesting so it is actually Christian
I guess trying to maybe push yeah
Christianity is trying to push but I
think Lenderman kind of built some sort
of a fortress yes
be really hard perhaps still kind of
understand this position but uh I want
to mention once again some stuff like
even if White's not forced to right we
just had this position but even if white
decided all of a sudden to go H5 let's
say to go H6 and then wait like this and
black will go here and take the spawns
it's two pawns up but with such a with
such a blockade I don't believe black
has any chances are going nowhere so
okay most likely result here then will
be a draw yeah and and that'd be still
very nice for Lenderman I understand he
has already won the tournament but you
know finishing undefeated yes it does
feel a lot better one dagger at the end
could be pretty good right maybe we can
just take a really brief look at some of
these B groups yeah let's just just uh
see what the actual positions are uh
Brendan Jacobson with tigran harutinyan
that's the one here which is unlike
lindeman's game is packed with action
right so there's a lot of stuff a lot of
pieces on the board
um look at that Bishop that's kind of
funny yeah he's funny indeed uh one of
the things to do with white like I do
see kind of two tempting moves like
Queen B4 just blockading and laughing
like if this works that'd be even better
Knight to C2 and then put the Knight on
B4 the problem with Knight C2 yeah of
course I'd be happy to do it but the
problem with Knight C2 is this little
move Knight E5 so we've you know lost
connection between the Rooks and black
immediately uses in a tactical way
Knight to E5
yeah you take the night take the rook
and if white captures only seven then
this happens Knight F3 we lose the queen
it's probably not the end though because
white can go to H1 uh black captures
uh the Queen White captures the room
writes the two Rooks for the queen but I
guess in the starting position in the
position we have currently on the board
White's chances are much better and here
God knows what's going on maybe what's
you know maybe White's in trouble after
say Knight D3 so perhaps white has to
avoid this line and yeah look for
something better not sure maybe maybe
just invade with both Rooks the one on
the C7 or one on C6 and then plan for
this Knight C2 Knight before so
positionally I like why it's set up a
lot interesting all right looking good
for Brandon Jacobson what else do we
have in the video yeah we have a draw
between Michael learn and Christopher
you and as I said like we are checking
the final positions let's go from say
move 20 all right uh just quickly so
that's
some opening ended up being born up for
white Rook C8 Queen H4 can't take it
right now the DH Rook is hanging after
all the trades okay Knight C7 Rook to E5
yeah feels like White's getting
somewhere
396 Queen C4
all right and that is that is how black
wins the pawn back traded Rook C6 and
then he simply doubles right
okay the white can't do much all right
in a few moves they just found some some
repetition and okay and that was it
beautiful uh Chandra actually
okay once again relieving a lot of
pieces on the board and it's only move
18.
only move 18 so here we are talking he
what's it called the Queen's Indian the
Queen's Indian
with B6 which used to be like you know
the opening of the world championship
matches and such yeah nowadays it's
practically extinct from the high
profile tournament practice
all those years these remember all those
lines we were analyzing like even
pre-computed era
so all that must be in the books I mean
must be known I don't know if the
players actually knew it
everybody knows everything that made it
go extinct rather than yeah yeah
building itself quite possibly quite
possibly yeah well very often what
happens is that some position considered
to be unpleasant by the big guys and
they stop playing it and we are we are
you know we let's say the next
that's right okay Magnus played a very
nice it's much easier yeah it's much
easier to equalize in the Queen's Gambit
than only the Queen's Indian for
instance right sure uh we you know do a
little research mostly hitting the
display the space button and and for
those who doesn't know like when you
analyze with the chess engine uh hitting
the biggest button on your keyboards
you're the best move to play yeah it
enters in your file it enters the the
move that currently suggests it's a
pretty much like yeah okay first line
works it's equal yeah let's play it and
we don't even have an idea what was
wrong with the previous one nobody plays
it yep you always trust when the top
people stop uh all right anyways and now
we do have some quite a conflict in the
center right so black gets uh well
hanging pawns but they by no stretch of
imagination they look weak now so it's
actually like Blackwell at some point
like push the pawn to D4 Knight will get
a square on C3 it's more about white
having you know the e-pawn E6 might be
disturbing at some point so that's a
very complex position I want to say
yeah and a few moments
Rook C1 sorry not DC Rook C1 oh it's
updated in fact it was saying dc5 it
wasn't it was my move rookie wants and
disregard what I just said okay no
hanging pawns okay there should be seven
Queen E7 okay Rook E1 Queen to B7 King
G1
H6 H5 so it's actually quite a few moves
and only then he takes but yeah that's
completely different story it's actually
black just getting very pleasant
position it looks like
so it's all about can you take on C5 or
not and and the answer is not because
Knight F3 right yep very nice states
only one is hanging
so white ended up playing some Knight D3
Trading still two pawns hangings perhaps
white even gets the pawn back but It's
Tricky D4 and our rookie one is a threat
so white girls with a check King a shade
Queen to D5 all right
it's a snail like black can make it
drool pretty much any time by trading
the Queens going after the apron
can he play for a win that's a big
question because now he's white
controlling the long diagonal more often
than not he could be safe yeah
so that's what we are going on in
the children
right then lenderman's game we have
already checked so we are left with
contour and cut Ridge and here once
again since it's the game in progress
I'm not returning to move one and just
look at this one and this looks terrible
for black considering why it's the move
as well symmetrical structure like no
one has like a big Center passport or
something white has more space and how
about those those two thingies which
supposed to be Knights but somehow they
are not they are not very active I want
to say kind of a weird Square yeah
that's a no I mean I'm 100 sure it's a
very bad position
yeah that's what's going on here uh it
is probably worth taking going back to
the a section this is where everything
will be determined today all right and
maybe we can check
however you want to do it here nothing
has happened in fact enhance this game
uh you Yang Yi yeah is there any
progress
who B3
The Rook went only four not E2 which
probably is clever in some cases he'll
be taking on E5 and guarding the bishop
at the same time maybe one day The Rook
is going to go to G4 rookie eight Rook
to E1 King h8 now can you explain King
to AJ King to h8 uh well I guess he's
getting rid of those tactics so now he's
maybe taking the a Pawn Yeah well G6 is
what he wants to play okay to kind of to
get rid of this queen on F5 which is
very annoying pins on the fifth rank
right targets the Knight and you can't
play G6 straight up because Queen G6 and
the F7 opponent spin so so that that's
interesting perhaps it's not that I'm a
big fan of this one and and let me check
one thing uh so he spent seven minutes
right on the previous move and now he
quickly played King of Chase okay
exactly so now
still too early for white to capture I
would guess even though who knows I mean
it's like everything is kind of cross
it's about as much you know like it's
sometimes as beginners you know like as
soon as one thing is attacking it you
gotta kind of get used to that sometimes
people like oh there's two or three
things it's hard this is everything that
could possibly you gotta count up to
four or five to understand what's
happening to be perfectly honest I mean
even to understand that is it possible
the cup J5 or not I'm afraid I might be
going back to the basics like when they
teach the beginners right uh you have to
count how many how many how many other
Bishop takes
yeah but imagine you're like a complete
beginner so you okay don't really know
how calculating the line works and they
would teach like count how many times
the thing is attacked and how many times
it's defended and then we can it's like
one you know one two three four five and
he guards as one two three four five so
for now it is
anyway yeah no I mean this really looks
terrifying Bishop takes B3 is what he
has done interesting and now yeah I mean
any kind of Contour counter play connect
with before now I don't think it works
at all because of White's rookie form of
white capture is only five Queen B3
logically white captures on F6 and now
the Rook on E7 is hanging you can't
really kind of Simply take on F6 so you
have to take on e4 and then white takes
on G7 first then takes only four and
whites two pawns up and also the king is
terrible so yeah I think this this is
this has to be the winning line has to
be the winning line so things look
pretty green taking control of his
Destiny he needs to win this one if he
wants to just win the tournament
outright today without a playoff all
right so let's check the other games one
win versus a Colby and Jacobian this one
well it looked more kind of more drawish
than anything
uh shall we shall we quickly check for
this
one like draws or something in that game
this would be the game to look at to see
who might be playing in the playoffs all
right so here we are talking about
so-called drugs this is cool now defense
yeah this bishop tournament very popular
Bishop G5 H6 Bishop takes Queen takes
and I think we uh we had it with uh the
inclusion of this trade and that then it
is a little bit different if you
remember Queen B3 I think it was one of
the games yesterday like the bones were
traded and queen D6 was the move now
logically you can't really play Queen D6
so C5 C takes he takes
uh D takes C5 and then black trades
everything on C3 Knight A6 Rook D1
Bishop E6
E4 I'm not sure about Bishop E6 to be
honest once again I do remember times
when this would be considered sufficient
compensation B6 and then quite quickly
Bishop E6 and so on so white is a pawn
up but he is somewhat undeveloped black
has a very nice Knight on C5 and people
would claim that this is enough
compensation so Bishop B6 is a bit
greedier but allows yeah allows wide for
this transformation Knight to D4 Rook C8
and then yeah capturing only six leads
nowhere yeah I guess you could try to
argue the Knight is better than the
bishop yeah yeah I think that that's the
whole point like he's trying to preserve
the pawn for now Bishop C4 King D2
Castle's King E3
Bishop to B5 Targets this Pawn Rook to
C1 C5
F5 G3 G5 C4
all right Bishop D5 was a clever
resource because otherwise black is
actually in trouble right like move the
bishop I'll take H6 and who knows but
Bishop D5 targeting this guy and then F4
happens King D2 and then E3 and F3 and
now this Pawn is a runner all right
black broke through uh so check over
there King H7 yeah not to be confused
with King H6 because it's yeah yeah I
remember Chad it's always
asking for help mate or complaints about
it
check here King h8 now Rook A6 so
technically it is a repetition if both
sides agree to do so but I don't think
white is looking for one
even though it wants to keep his playoff
hopes alive he doesn't need to win here
I mean you gotta see is at least gonna
draw yeah that will be on the head for a
drive yeah on the other hand do you win
I mean that's two is such a threat maybe
that's maybe that's White's chance to
you know yeah if you can't I guess he
can't but uh um that might knock Von
Nguyen out of contention
so that's the one then we have Neiman's
game when well well
yeah so we've seen something like this
he him hovering around on the sixth rank
like Rook A6 B6 like how is white
actually going to break through D1 he
captured went Rook to G6 now potentially
yeah interesting
G4 G5 but does he have does he get
anywhere oh no okay he goes G5 takes
takes and now the Rook on G5 attacks
both pawns Black's gonna go King F6 yeah
perhaps it's still it's logical
follow-up you you have to do something
right so it's a logical follow-up but
will it really feels like there's too
much pressure on D3 to ever get that
other Rook into the game
so the only way of guarding the tree and
then kind of trying to make progress
would be getting the Rook to D5 but it
takes quite a lot of moves and black
black will be with his thing only six by
then
right so I'm guessing Okay
you can't do much I'm afraid yeah if
draw potentially for Hans Neiman
all right we will see still coming up
what else is going on in the a group
yeah right any opportunity to sacrifice
the tree charts asking it's kind of
tough
it's kind of tough I'm guessing I guess
they're thinking of bringing the key
yeah like F3 right so you probably have
to go like G5 H6 get rid of those spawns
and then somehow try to use the Rooks
but once again it's easier said than
done might be something you can try
though without risking too much uh no no
he he clearly doesn't risk anything and
yeah here uh here we go complaints in
the chat commentators ignoring video
uh yeah my fault I was planning planning
to look at it at some point we have a
lot of Ilia fans all right at some point
vidit was like very close to winning the
game it felt like at least but that's
very often the case with zelia's his
openings are like not
not always
himself too uh right but then yeah then
when the actual game starts he's he's
very good Bishop to E7 Knight takes Pawn
takes
and that's one very pop it used to be
very populous a line in the
semi slav or yeah going to C2 Knight D7
castles long that's White's attempt kind
of modern attempt to play this one A6
key to B1 captures here Bishop C4 C5
wasn't it like B5 C5 but once again it
might be might be confusing stuff
white girls with G4 trade here Knight B6
Bishop B3 and this is something perhaps
a bit too slow from Black
Rook C8 Queen to D3 Knight D5 traded and
then yeah it does look like a nice
blockade Square on D5 the isolated Pawn
for white but black is still uncastled
and white uses this momentum for going
F4 F5 undermining the D5 Outpost Queen
to D7 F5 just like that
and rookie one and now once again you
can't Castle because Bishop D5 the
bishop 187 is hanging
you can't lift The Rook because H6 is
under control because sometimes that'd
be that'd be the way to go look at these
interesting defensive resources yeah so
he ended up going Knight F6 Rook to E5
white threatens to double on the e-files
and now you do not have all that much of
a choice King fade Rook F5 and this is
yeah this is better for white yeah
clearly Rook F1 takes A3 even though
black is a pawner but the king is like
in constant danger rookie one and Rook
F1 and queen F3 so
I got all three pieces on the B file B5
Bishop C6 B4 so that's what we have
that's what we have right now all right
so we'll keep coming back to this one
I've I've heard that we may have a
blunder in group b somebody looking for
second place the aksha Chandra game is
worth going back to and talking about
yeah let me see
okay okay so Queen to D5 Queen E7
happened and white captured on D4
and that perhaps leaving the diagonal
you you told us yeah and then it's yeah
it goes like capture and if you take
back I presume something like this
happens and the check
and yeah we kept talking about this
important the importance of this
diagonal so now it's check forcing the
king in the open and rookie four and
black winds okay we can see there the
players have ended the game this is a
win for ronak satwani oh yeah so Rook F5
Queen E6 Rook F3 Queen to H3 and I was
brilliant because rookie one strappeding
as well as Queen H2 and white simply has
no move all right well a very good
finish for uh sadwani here at the end so
he is guaranteed to tie for the second
well wonderful perhaps on uh unlikely to
take the second loan because for this
everybody else
right so we'll see what happens there uh
all right maybe back to a yeah back to a
because we still have yeah we have uh
nishnik's game on the screen so b4a
before okay I don't quite get this B
full move to be perfectly honest because
you will still need to move the Rook
unless Elia is planning to take over
here but for now I don't see I don't see
how does that work Bishop E8 Bishop C3
Queen takes c39 no it probably doesn't
probably doesn't so so b4a B4 okay and
then then black will still need to move
the Rook
it could be
yeah it could be still problematic for
Ilia all right keeping our eyes on this
one ah there was one game with which we
didn't touch at all even though it might
be it might be an absolute Brilliance
here so yeah Nicholas theodoro is black
has got one of our only gambits in the
entire tournament right it's like he
played oops yeah sorry it starts jumping
so he played uh what's called the Shara
again
yep it's a cop trainish here and then
instead of recapturing which would lead
to Tara's defense C takes D4 right a
check Bishop D7
uh take so here and you have you know
Magnus Carlson played this one against
the equine against shankland that's
black right grease yeah played it
against
um
yeah Knight to F6
and nowadays nobody takes the second
opponent considered to be like just oval
of the Knight C6 I believe so Queen to
G5 is what the boss of is doing Bishop
to B2 H6 and it ends up with the queen
on G3
Bishop to C5 now apparently you cannot
take this really
you cannot take this dude because Rook
G8 Queen takes and I wonder what's
stronger because Knight G4 also seems to
be very but I mean but yeah normally we
humans we tend to show off so Bishop F2
of course is what I'm playing right I
mean there's a fork to win the queen
yeah and then yeah then the G4 beautiful
anyway sir
and it tends to be quite awkward for
white right and he also spots like
everything else The Rook C1 castles
Knight H3 and you're not happy with kind
of normal moves normal move being Knight
F3 perhaps I'm actually not sure why he
wasn't happy Knight H5 still doesn't win
right there is a square on H4 you always
have to look where the queen yeah but
the Queen's very easy to get trapped
yeah absolutely the queen is in trouble
anyway so he went Knight day three night
to D4 and now it's just a disaster E3
rookie eight beautiful
Queen H4 you have to play like all the
awkward moves here and this bike just
keeps improving yeah let's talk about
dream scenario for black you don't have
to like you know go for something to
anything crazy yeah you just you're just
building up your position slowly and
white can't really can't really keep up
Knight E4 Rook to D1 Knight F2 wow this
is this is
this is a blow okay thanks we need five
check this guy these guys paint look I
mean
three Bishop E3 Queen G4 and it never
stops it's like yeah five Queen F5
targeting this guy Knight D3 rookie to
d8
uh Bishop E2 Bishop G2 Rook F1 Bishop F1
[Music]
it must be completely winning uh Bishop
F1 Queen F3 is what followed oh boy I
love that there's been this like
Discovery potential for so long and I
just never use it yeah yeah absolutely
so now black is also material up he has
two two phones on The Rook against two
knights but who cares about the material
yeah a white Place yeah white plays A4
that's the best you got because you have
to play the move yeah that's the point
yeah you can just just pass oh
who has the white pieces here he won in
the first round he won the game in about
21 moves he was actually the winner on
the side of kind of like an opening
disaster here it's looking like maybe
he's going to be caught on the other end
of the spectrum uh potentially kind of
the victim of a brutal loss early on in
the opening I don't know if it's you
know if he's having fun here because I
believe black has a better move than A5
but why not I mean come on don't do them
like that little crew
like that hey five again
it's so cold
terrible terrible thing to do lovely
though
all right so yeah really fun we'll come
back and we'll see how this game ended
up being a win for black all right
so there is that and what do we yeah
yeah any requests from the chat yeah
okay well then I think we know what they
want they want Hans and even hands but
yeah
back to this situation but like everyone
requests Hans game it's a lowest
position out of them all right that's
fine we can all learn something here uh
overall I go right he actually does make
some progress and now this regards the
tree he goes King D2 and he so now does
he have the chance he's got his two
Roots defending one yeah well he's not
trying to run the king all the way over
no no no no no I think where's his King
going this way black might have
underestimated the danger
because now okay I mean you can give a
check and then you can see three but
then the Rook can be freed on the next
move right yeah if you can get these
Rooks going and otherwise if you keep
waiting I think it's just Rook G1
and then he what he's threatening is
check and then take the guy with a check
so the D3 is not lost in the process
yeah wait a minute yeah yeah
is played Rook B2 is played
yeah that that's what I'm that's what
I'm suggesting he has to do
um the only question is like if this is
something remotely close to a Perpetual
check like when saying now if white just
plays Rook G1 I assume it checks all the
way right yeah that's like uh but white
has a check over here King yells and
then has a check over here and King
perhaps goes to G8 and now with all
those checks I mean if
it's like the same checks all the time
maybe I can run to it yeah I leave it to
hands to calculate he did get a king C3
but okay this game is not done there's
some actual danger here though this is
actually maybe something uh to keep
watching wow look at that yeah so
everyone's trying I mean we keep saying
that yeah you Yankee wins and that's all
yeah let's not forget I mean there's
some money at stake absolutely
so yeah all right we will be keeping our
attention here on Hans Neiman and seeing
if he can he'd be finishing with two
wins in a row which would be quite a
massive way to start off the next of the
next uh sorry series of yeah there's
been seven rows in a row now two wins
and he's looking for another tournament
and speaking of draws we just have a
result in the Jacobian game we can take
a real quick glance at it yeah I think
we've actually seen like pretty much
everything almost till the end
uh not really yeah that was that was the
moment remember that when yeah they've
started repeating Rook to C7 so black
actually honestly tries to play it and
white found nothing better but to
capture this pawn and luckily for white
it's the last black spawn remaining so
Whitehead perhaps no difficulty Ah
that's a that's a brilliant solution I
mean not to not to suffer or anything in
this rook and Bishop versus Rook just
calculate a couple of lines take over
here joking D5 go CC for wind now that
means the only road to a playoff is a Yu
Yang Yi loss which the last time we
checked in seems almost impossible uh
not really we still have with it right
if Reddit wins sure
win himself and his opportunities here
have kind of yeah yeah so he he is
waiting for you Yankee to lose well look
Yankee blonde is a queen loses that's
pretty much what would have to happen
when it makes a draw enhance wins and
what's then and we have four people tied
for the first and uh yeah
in those playoffs when we get there a
time
doesn't suggest anything about it has
happened before we've had crazy busy
stuff all right we have a result
Nicholas theodoro wins the vine hunting
yeah yeah
wins just let's check what was what was
the loss I'm being reminded by my
producers I've been doing a bad job
promoting my own videos but we do on the
St Louis chess club Channel have an
excellent video on the Yvonne heading
Shara Gambit that everybody can look up
all right so Bishop to
Bishop to uh wants the square called G5
Queen E3 and you can't really stop the
shipping I mean it's such a picture
[Music]
yeah yeah
beautiful game by Nicholas theodoro it
really has to be said that was actually
a marvelous game uh right that leaves us
with yeah with three games of uh
tournament favorites we've checked
hans's game we've checked uh uh Village
game we will check right now uh right
sir was there any special plan of the
b4a before not really Rook B8 rookie one
and queen to A7
um
right but the feeling is that's the
moment where white captures on F6 twice
and wins
for whatever reason I do believe this
should work okay
who knows once again we could give it a
whirl yeah like point being yeah take
care twice okay uh The Bishop's hanging
no Bishop before because a check May
donate at the end yeah Bishop takes and
uh beautiful Bishop E8 so the only thing
which is which is kind of left to find
out is something like Bishop to E7
and then regrettably oh wow why is that
why regrettably no I'm gonna double
attack no you you actually do have
double attack on these two Rooks nothing
can check on the background and
interestingly yeah I mean initially I
thought no but there is a check but
there isn't yeah
right and then queen of four two Rooks
attacked and white picks one of the
Rooks and moreover you can try to get
the bishop for it but you are getting
checkmated on a chain oh my God in the
very end how wonderful I mean I wonder
if this works I mean I'm purely kind of
going by the feeling I mean I want to
sacrifice on F6 to open the key yeah
[Music]
let me let me see Rook takes F6 plus 10.
look at that
this could be a potential win for vidit
who then would have who then would need
to be watching the Yu Yang Yi game
hoping for a draw yes why don't we watch
you in ge's game yeah what is happening
uh what's happening here yeah yeah he's
up a pawn now and he's the move oh okay
that that changes a lot because I was
about to say that after all what
happened to black I mean maybe he's not
that much in the end but yeah yeah but
still still yeah still hard and
yeah I wonder what I'm doing here with
white
kind of taking this guy or trying to
yeah that's not not so easy because
takes over here
black captions with the Knight I'm
guessing
so it's a technical position yeah you
regrettably you can't really like go and
win
you can't really go and win you probably
play some sort of King F1 black lives
the Knight we trade ropes it must be a
winning position with the two Bishops
and an extra Pawn but it'll take some
you know some time to convert
alternatively it could be that some move
is better that I've just suggested I
don't know I go Bishop C4 maybe Target
this guy because if black cartridge we
are getting the same material
it's be it'd be the D Pawn instead of C
pawn and who knows what which one's
better
but yeah okay so but in both cases you
know like black does not resign
immediately at least right he's trying
it's probably still a lost position this
one but he's still trying and a lot of
players hoping to catch up with first
place do need you to draw this game or
at least draw the game oh yeah uh but it
looks I mean he's pressing he's trying
to win maybe right I wonder I wonder if
he just missed some you know some
something here yeah he captured on B3 G6
Queen F3 Bishop G7 Rook four point one
or more forceful he missed like a yeah
to be honest that's the feeling like
white was kind of close to yeah de5 was
like plus four or something for whatever
reason he should have yeah the trick is
such I mean he should have corruptured
and then it doesn't matter what black
takes with he takes on B3 it's not easy
to comprehend because remember we're
gonna talk really just can't really tell
how many times the 925s attacked and
defended but for computer you know no
problem yeah no problem it calculates it
beautifully and it turns out yeah all
those pins are too much for black people
yeah and this is like almost an extra
Rook with equal material yeah uh right
and what he has done Bishop I'm sorry
Bishop B3 G6 I mean it's still much
better of course but this is not as kind
of as decisive and and then he played
close to perfect I'm guessing Queen C6
Queen B4 Queen C3 okay drops an
advantage a little bit but still like
very close to be winning
all right okay so still all the chances
for You Yankee to well run away with his
win absolutely is all in his control if
he can win this game he will be our
tournament a champion and it is worth
reminding you that he just won the 2022
summer chess classic so he could be the
back-to-back winner that'd be the first
time that anyone has actually won this
series uh two times in a row so this is
huge
right that thing did he is impressive uh
shall we once again go back to the big
group to yeah let's take a look around
huge huge fight for the second place
that one has already finished we still
have three games going uh Jacobson
against harutinyan sure this looks kind
of fun yeah there was this this one's
attacking it was this moment yeah when
we were discussing how to block B4 and
Rook one to C6 was played the move that
I've suggested and now probably should
have should have thought better uh Queen
before the bishop is still passive Rook
to D7 H3 while H3 anyway
traded h3h4 yeah that I mean it feels
like white loses a thread here like the
night Still Remains only three the night
which otherwise would have been like on
B4 or something you can have three
Knight C2 Rook F5 these guys attacked
and after Queen D2 black actually goes
before so now you can take the Ballon
you cannot because Bishop e no you can
Bishop E2 still like Queen E1 right but
the bishop comes back having something
right uh Bishop is coming back to life
I'm not even sure if
white is not in a deep trouble like
let's say if the bishop gets there these
light squares it's you know somehow all
the experience
all the previous experience tells us
that this one dimensional attack should
not work so because black spends like
five you know five moves to travel
inject mate in one but how do you
actually stop yeah I mean when you know
what your opponent's gonna do Bishop of
three and and simple but King H2 yeah
yeah
ugly looking absolutely smash through
yeah so yeah very very dangerous for
Brandon James okay so Jacobson goes D5
which arguably could be a better move
yeah having some Queen D4 or rather
Knight D4 options in some cases yeah but
but then yeah black can also tried B3
and you know there is a past pawn and
who knows what happens there it's a very
sharp game once again it's most of uh
Brendan's games are
all right now I can see in the chat they
said
it's true uh yeah let's see video
against nishnik yes F6 is oh yes
captured he went with queen is Queen
four immediately hang on a second what's
my then and now I'm not yeah not backing
up yeah rookie seven is this is the
winning move is a blunder because it is
a winning move but black can kind of
bail out himself a little bit by taking
it yeah
and now the sad for a thing for white
that he can't actually take because
you'll be losing the other he'd be
losing the other bishopsy says white is
still winning but yeah like whatever
yeah they really want to involve in such
stuff probably not so did he play even
better than this so Queen F4 the move
that he ended up playing is in fact I'm
sorry not [ __ ] B7 yeah Queen F4 is much
stronger wow we have four Rook H7 75 and
it's beautiful
it's Total Domination so now
you set the exchange and then you just
kind of improvement yeah if you want to
know I mean he still has a beautiful
finish here just push the pawn
D6 you hung up on and queen D6 oh look
at those Bishops oh my gosh they're so
good look at that that'd be a lovely
finish to this absolutely yeah
I think yeah I think I mean black
technically still can kind of pretend he
is not done but yeah for how long can
you do it
so vivid kind of on the verge of winning
this final game against Ilia niejnik but
really it all comes down to the U game
like if you is somehow able to win oh
yep that ends the conversation
so I think what is what is he up to if
we had any moves here right a lot of
simplifies he's stupid but for the time
being his Bishop is wow kinda out of the
game I don't see how it kind of fixes
all the problems because sooner or later
White's gonna play you know an ugly
looking move G3 and then depending on
how you react to this one like if you
guard the F4 Port I'm happily taking say
and and the bishop is relatively free
maybe go King G2 if you push F3 White's
gonna go G3 G4 open the diagonal so I
think he's done
uh Bishop to C4 F4 was
um black has played a four and G5 okay
this is how we've gotten there so you
kind of gave away simplify but if
White's Bishop yeah dark spot Bishop
breaks out hang on a second do we
do we keep both pawns alive though that
is my question because I just yeah I
just realized the five night B6 and I
can't really make a decision can't
really stop both I'll probably keep A5
right so Knights are notoriously bad
stopping you know the root points ah I'm
actually winning like almost by force
I'm guessing Bishop here maybe win the
night my girls whatever it goes I don't
know before A6 Bishop D4 the pawn is
stopped for now but then you go King F1
Bishop G1
hmm yeah this must be it
looks like
G3 then yeah and still he he seems to be
completely winning here we could
potentially have a back-to-back classic
Champion winner so how about checking
hans's game
is this Sunday
like okay okay fair enough he did make
it a lot of progress here so check Rook
H2 Rook to G6 was he fools for this G6
check
ah how wonderful
so I was originally planning to go here
but then black apparently has a
Perpetual hmm
because my argument was that the king
just came out
but yeah but there is another rook and
you can get checkmated oh don't do
it so in fact yeah
in fact this is a Perpetual because you
probably have to stay kind of on the
third right
so that's why that's why he gives a
check first then he goes Rook G1 and now
uh in case of those checks he can run to
c4d5 something yeah
and Blackness King f8
okay
so now white would be happy to say trade
the H Pawn for e-pawn somehow white
would be happy with kind of many many
things but but how do you get any of
those
um
again I'm not sure yeah I mean yeah if
this works if this works then then
you're just thinking here very cool
right then it's very cool but also there
is like Rook H3 or another attempt for a
Perpetual
because this King for instance it's also
unsafe sort of
well uh we will definitely be keeping
our eyes here but huge breaking news we
do have a winner in the a group and his
name is Yu Yang Yi he has officially won
his game today and with that uh is going
to be the winner of the a group uh yeah
so just final moves over here CD4 and
there was no move
this was the very foreign
so wow huge things so huge
congratulations of course to you Yang Yi
winning his second classic in a row and
a huge congratulations to Alex Linderman
we know both of our Champions and there
he is Yu Yang Yi walking away with 6 000
US dollars in his pockets a huge
congratulations to him played a great
tournament
um I think it's it was exactly the same
as the Summer Classic where I think he
kind of started a little bit slow but it
was quite he finishes incredibly strong
every single time yeah so what's his
final score I'm getting confused there
so he's gonna be on six and a half six
and a half six
yeah very slow
and a drawing one another one yeah
that's quite impressive you know some
quarterbacks you know they play like
okay all game some play good in the
fourth quarter and some people don't you
Yang Yi he's one of those guys that can
win you a Super Bowl uh all right all
right and we have one more result vidit
Gujarati wins and that means he takes
clear second absolutely were there any
additional moves in this game yeah the
Final Touch that's the did he get a nice
beautiful place here he did play D6 yeah
but we're denying all the beauty I mean
yeah in this position it's like you
probably you understood since yeah he
understands but I think for the fans one
more time you probably have to capture
yeah I think you have to capture with
something obviously yeah you have to
capture you have to allow this I think
yeah
all right so our Rocky end to the
tournament for ilionic but uh
an amazing win if I hit it the sacrifice
was really I was a very very cool game I
think like kind of quality game maybe
not always top computers choices but
yeah very very good quality overall very
nice game all right and I guess we can
just kind of keep our eyes on some of
the other games what
one I mean that means that in the age
group we only
have
this one the end game that's all you
need again
yeah Hans is still playing uh so he's
the other Rook to attack
so what do we have for now Yu Yang Yi
has won first place visit second place
if Hans wins he dies for the third third
place yeah yeah dies for the Third
and theodoro has won does it now he has
less points than Hans yeah yeah so if
Hunters are much less yeah he's came
into you again all right with his win
today he'll have three and a half points
and the B tournament we have uh well we
do have some results I don't know what's
that is that the real thing
yeah that Brandon Jacobson's game of
this D5 black went Bishop E2 Queen E1
Rook to D5 Knight to D4
Rook takes D4 was played okay that's
nice Rook takes D4
perhaps hoping for this and then some E3
you know and White Queen A1 so he's
tricky Queen A1 pins this road king H6
Queen takes D4
so now a white is in sort of in a bit of
a trouble in the long run if black ever
gets to those lights quests but black
king is not say safe itself
King is more unsafe than they are still
kind of crazy crazy that you can't
really evaluate these position so I
would go and say then why it's probably
better but but yeah once again I mean
one thing why it's better the other
thing but who's more likely to get
checkmated his white Checkmate or black
check mated exactly so so the game is
not done by any means very fun one ronak
sadwani has won I don't remember if
we've mentioned this
uh we looked at their game at some point
I believe like somewhere ah yeah yeah
that was long time ago right
uh that's the one that's the one yeah so
that was one of the first games yeah so
he guarantees himself a tie for the
second Contour with cartridge that's the
position after a lot of stuff happened
well cut Ridge is fighting that was uh
Converses game was uh when is sack uh
here somehow black managed to develop
remember
I was making fun of those nights maybe I
wasn't right
yeah
here it look here it looked like
desperate for black if you ask me okay
but why perhaps kind of slow played it a
little bit
I mean as you kind of go through these
games I think we're actually going to
set up for an interview right here in
the studio so I'll let you continue
going through this all right I believe
we might have the winner of the a group
with us in just about a year young year
will be joining us oh that's cool
so cartridge coverage yeah we will
fought back and not in a bad way
um right Queen six track
and that's the position
that's the position all right
all righty all right as we're kind of
getting ready for our interview is there
anything else yeah just quickly Jacobson
we've already checked here just to
understand what's going on
well I don't think white wins it's
controversial opinion I know but yeah
perhaps you've lost his jail he's lost
his chance like now if he has to trade
the Queens he's a pawner but black is
very very active and then yeah that's
Brandon Jacobson and Lenderman with
cherila the game goes on but how do you
yeah well I don't see black making any
any sort of meaningful progress here
yeah people do have requests for vivid
interview
that of course would be
I'm
I would be very happy
all right so a little bit of a change up
we actually do not currently have an
interview with Yu Yang Yi or with vidit
unfortunately but uh if we ever get them
we'll obviously bring them all right all
right
um doesn't mean they prepare for the
ceremonial dinners I guess yeah now we
were quick uh you know some people they
like to linger when they win you know
they linger around and they're very
happy and I guess some people are a
fleet of foot but uh if we get them
we'll obviously let you guys know
um and okay with all of that we got a
couple games going on in the B group
tell me more about Hans though come on
yeah give me the good stuff fans yeah so
this is clever though right using this
other Rook to potentially go after the
epon this seems like a clever try all
right but what's the what's the
difference if still the check is played
that's something I'm not sure yet
all right so we play King B3 yep so now
by the way King B4 would be an awesome
an awkward move I'm trying to avoid this
scenario because King A3 Rook say B5
will be six yeah and I'm not sure maybe
don't check maybe yup it's gonna happen
so it means yakim B3 and the idea is if
you keep checking then maybe I can run
towards your E5 four and the check and
here in the check and you can
or even this sure even this and then
this I like it here in this track here
and it's been a been a lot of moves with
the King but it feels like it runs away
eventually
did I make any progress I don't know but
I had fun yeah running around yeah
and but what else can be done I mean E5
pawns hanging whenever you make like one
passive movie is black I believe you're
never coming back from this one so here
I don't know it's like a check Rook F5
is an idea Rogue G2 might be there here
as well because now black is quite
passive let's say this position black is
quite passive and then King F7 there'll
be some Rook G6 cutting the king off the
E Pawn
so here I would believe why it's
probably trans and black needs to avoid
uh right but we've got this 30 minutes
increment so obviously Ganguly tries to
figure out what what exactly is the way
to hold this one time control is 45 plus
10 now
yeah so these are long games this is 90
plus 30 and then at move 30 they do
receive that additional 30 minutes so I
have to move 40 they'll have had an
entirety of uh two hours but they're
also getting that 30 second increment
every single move yeah people suggest
yeah let's go Rook H3 that's fair but
then we want to trade a rook if we're
white we want to trade G3 I guess and
it's Force blocks forced to trade I'm
not saying not saying that black is lost
this way immediately sure it seems that
compared to the position where white
couldn't like move at all yes
at least now you can you can yeah you
can try
so this game will keep going you'll feel
like
okay all right so this is it uh let's
think I just thought yeah uh the best
games the best games of today's round
it's relatively easy I mean I really
like video's game yes again I think it's
a very good one and yeah game Nicholas
Theodore Nicholas theodoro yeah so today
we have quite a few quite a few nice
games every day we've had a couple
games
oh the B the B group
oh this one's still going oh this one's
still going is someone trying to win
here don't think
well is Lenderman trying to win
no it's Christian obviously is trying to
win yeah it's really hard to imagine
these black puns ever can move like in
any situation
right
so we'll see cartridge it's this and ah
the Queen's end game he went for after
King G7 Queen to C1
so this happened
check but then he probably can't really
avoid the perpetual
like he what you have to do is what G3 I
guess
and even this one's not guaranteed that
you're avoiding a Perpetual right
because black can still continue
checking but also I'm not sure if black
loses this one at all Queen A3 Who's
Back who's better yeah this one's
attacked there is no check these six
black captures both of those G3 and D6
the yeah white shouldn't be losing after
some Queen F4 because black king is also
exposed but I don't think yeah I don't
think it's white her place for win so
logically it still should end in a draw
which actually means that runx and wani
he'll be I guess he'll be alone is he in
the player second that'd be kind of
crazy yes literally six people that were
kind of vying for that we felt like the
tie for the second was inevitable but um
clear second place winner might just be
everything's just clear like normally
these things are always coming down to
these crazy Wild playoffs but maybe this
year this is just the year of just
ice and we've worked it out the year of
clarity
okay
uh so Jacobson's game if you will is
the most entertaining for now
Queen D4 and black kind backs up a
little by going Queen F5 but gotta back
up down to H3 yeah now that I realize
that if you do not create like a serious
threat and let's yeah let's pretend okay
yeah I thought I thought this was
annoying Queen H3 and then F1 and Bishop
Street but I think why it's just on time
and queen F1 is yeah you just moved the
Rook protector you go away and then
you're threatening disc with a four and
Rook F7 so still they are kind of uh
this is busted for black uh could be
could be
anyway right so at least he's kind of
guaranteed to drop the E4 Pawn I don't
know if it's the end of uh if it's the
end of it interestingly enough people
like some counter play with it look like
black wouldn't be unhappy to get to an
end game because yeah these phones are
very close to promotion square and the
king is cut off but how do you trade the
Queens right it's a queen G4 Rook f
once again yeah could be that black is
just busted here I know Queen yeah wow
well actually
now that I'm thinking could it be that
what just wins like Rook F7 doesn't even
need Queen E4 because this is still one
check only and Bishop F3 threatens the
Checkmate which white cannot avoid but
he doesn't need to because he's the one
who Checkmate The Black Keys uh yeah
yeah that's what I wanted because I was
about to say there is I can see three
ways three ways of white chick mating in
two it's Queen E5 and G5 right it's
Queen H7 Queen G6 but of course once
again must show off yeah of course Rook
F5 and queen G5 Checkmate all Rook G5
Checkmate after I mean here
uh it's a philosophical question because
this one is shorter but how can you stop
yourself
I mean you cannot drive just for fun you
cannot anyway anyway that only means
that White's winning after Rook F6 and
yeah Jacobson's back to plus one I'm
guessing or fifty percent don't know I'm
a bit he was telling yourself he was
kind of off to a bad start but a win
here would bring him to four and a half
out of nine so a very respectable finish
potentially for Brandon
all righty
so one more result yeah counter gargle
counter and cartridge was a draw this
queen Sam game
uh downtown not this one once again
sorry yeah
basically a draw was agreed like
literally immediately okay King H1 not
even trying understandable fair enough
fair enough so it's only Lenderman will
you know will final dinner be delayed
because the winner that's just feels
really important questions you know
people in chat are never worried about
you know when our dinner time is gonna
start but it might be early today
because we do have winners in both
Fields uh-huh
we got to just follow Hans we don't have
too much time left in the coverage yeah
we gotta just fair enough
so okay okay so I just want to kind of
get a clear idea of the Hans game before
we so Rook 6 G5 was played check oops I
once again sorry yeah
okay still not too late I imagine to go
to H3 and force this uh yes
you're just letting me play one of the
Rooks
yeah to be perfectly one is now that
this check was already given what's
wrong with Rook D1 I'm asking myself
and I kind of want to I don't know keep
keep both Roots maybe actually yeah this
makes a whole lot of sense like Rook C5
all of a sudden will be a mistake
because with like all Rooks on the board
King gets access so you'll have to
you'll have to go like rookies Rook D7
technically is the move but then
perhaps even include Rook F5 so the king
cannot go to E file and after King G8 go
King C4 why it is making progress yeah
white suddenly makes progress maybe
maybe he's like
close to winning so I'm not even sure
what black is supposed to do
uh you can't really activate this Rook
any soda yes I think might yeah let's
let's press the magical button let's see
0.1 look at that major advantage point
one yeah uh I'm being silly yeah of
course you go here go here Rook D7
uh King C4 okay Rook D4
and I stopped calculating here because I
thought now of course green C3 and E5
cannot be protected but but there is
rookie four yeah yeah okay so rookie
four so that justifies defend this land
yeah that justifies it's a clean C4 in
fact allows black to pretty much make it
draw immediately if we consider this go
up and swap if you consider this one
being a draw which it is right sure
all right well I guess that looks like
uh potentially the eighth draw here for
Hans Neiman but uh that will actually
kind of conclude our show for the day uh
yeah it's been kind of a wonderful
experience having all of this
just kidding is what we we got him we
got them they thought we would end no we
got the Hans Neiman going on we would
never do it to you got em got em good
okay let's see
oh they fall for it every time yeah
absolutely and sometimes we do leave so
that's that's always dependent on that
Graphics guy you know the last day it's
a little bit harder to come up with
those graphics
uh right uh hang on a second so we do
have the winner it's you Yang Yi we have
Avid second and Hans in case he wins
he's tied for the third right yeah yeah
kind of adds up perfectly
what else is going on Brendan Jacobson
against haruchihan
C5 is what black played logical right
logicals uh uh what's the trade the
Queen's Queen E4 then and this is a
threat
so well this way at least
he's not he's not falling apart
immediately
uh are there more tricks to be
discovered I'm asking myself
go with them
Queen F4 I'm guessing but but that but
then White's not kind of not winning
just yet Bishop goes back to C4 targets
the board maybe maybe the game is on at
full swing kind of
what they do H5 would have been kind of
lovely to play but
you know what thanks I don't know H5
doesn't make any sense Queen takes
and when the Bishops captured group
sculpture so it's five beer nice to do
but
somehow hold on to this we were just
like all right that's it Brandon wins
he's up to four and a half points in G7
and there's more tactics I'm guessing
because after Bishop C6 can he can he
actually play can he can he play because
this one is honestly very confusing to
me I imagine it could be that white just
wins with Rook C4 but once again I
wouldn't be yeah probably he does
no no I I don't see how to you know how
to promote this thingy I mean you play
Bishop D3 and after you take the pawn
you play B5 yeah B5 again like goes A3
and then there's nothing right now
thinking B3 a bit big tree he can take
and take the bishop and still come back
yeah
so yeah maybe this is winning for white
once again yeah it is it is even though
it's not something yeah to keep the
Intrigue you know yeah yeah coming up
with some reason so that one and yeah
and the other one is lenderman's but
then then we might as well watch Hans
Neiman you know pay attention to this
Pawn structure it's going to be like
that for the rest of the game
absolutely this Pawn might move at that
point but not the other ones
expecting much there
but uh
yeah the Hans game is really
is really to kind of keep an eye on we
haven't even had a move here uh let's
see a while before we get an actual roof
so Rook D2 ah hang on but room D2 is not
the same as Rook H3 which the copy was
suggesting okay
could it be
how is it now
what's now what's up okay so what is
just threatening the Ebon point one
it makes sense that everything is a draw
but in you know
you know now you oh wait it's but just
out of curiosity so
I'm still
yeah D1
say if I'm capturing this guy that's a
good question to ask it's a draw because
this and I have to
guard the king like that and then it
should be four I mean how do you know
it's a draw I mean it's very easy yeah
but a computer tells you it's a draw you
have two pawns down but you attack the
king all the time but do you actually go
for this line I don't think so
um yeah and I'm guessing if you don't
find Rook D1 you might not make this
drone
so there's actually
it's actually quite unpleasant yes it's
a black it was easier for black
some defense here looks like Hans is
asking the critical questions he's
coming up with ways of trying to at
least threaten to make some progress in
the position
uh okay and remember we were at some
point pretty sizing eight tournament for
a lack of decisive games yeah so it's a
three out of four are already one by one
of the sides they you have to put the
guys Under Pressure because everyone
felt like ah okay maybe maybe it's time
to is that part of it I mean so at the
end of the tournament you typically I
guess see more decisive results
especially in like even in yes this
level of tournaments some people want
650 right I mean that that's is it
fatigue or is there also this element of
I'm trying to compete for a certain
prize a certain place and that compels
me to play more it could be it because
at some point like even if we only
consider money right sure it could be
like a price structure like four plus
prices are the same and then yes yes I
don't care if I lose I make a draw but
if I win big difference I guess yeah a
bit more so even with this motivation
you can imagine someone playing kind of
all out for a win and obviously there is
do you think it's more there's more
fatigue yes yeah somebody that easily
gets tired after These Guys these guys
have to be fit I believe but yeah anyway
you are not as fresh as in round one
wrong of course yeah that's of course
yeah also matters
uh Hans doesn't seem to be any any
stress I mean not his last interview
yesterday I mean he felt chill
yeah the game I won
very nice
uh all right so that's you know the
downside of this longish time control
that
you do not get the moves very quickly
and thankfully Hans at least like he's
playing it fast right so yes that's 46
minutes so again I think we kind of
touched on this like in an earlier thing
too so in this position if you're Hans
and you're kind of pressing you're up a
pawn and like it's okay it's probably a
draw but maybe the opponent could make a
mistake or whatever is this a good time
with the white pieces here do you try to
play as fast as you possibly can because
maybe it's just you know you just play
some stuff hoping to get them in time
trouble is this a good opportunity to do
that or do you still just take your time
and try to come up with yeah well most
accurate once again in in the ideal case
scenario you probably kind of stop when
you realize that it's hard to make a
progress
uh you think a little bit and you
identify what positions look promising
they say I escaped with the King to B3
from E3 okay if I get to this one then I
probably should calculate and then you
you yeah you play fast you Shuffle
around you give like random checks and
so on and then yeah if something changes
then of course yeah you stop again and
you calculate and try to figure it out
and for now yeah maybe Hans just on one
hand realizes it's a draw on the other
one yeah that doesn't really care that
much if let's say black finds it or not
finds it and does what he has to do he
has to activate the rules he has to try
yeah but that's the only one game going
uh theodoro We've checked right Theodore
yep we can take one last look around
uh yeah last stroke around is Neiman's
game uh
yep
yeah that can go forever yeah it feels
like we might be in the situation where
there's just not that much happening and
things are kind of already decided and
Jason Jacobson's game is still going but
yeah now we've reached this position but
why it pretty much has the forcing win
if he accomplishes and we'll conclude
our final broadcast here we will be
looking at the standings for the B group
all right let's find out
all right this is the B group all right
it does say the a group on the top but
this is the B group and we know the
winner it is Alex Linderman who is still
playing his game with Christian carrilla
but we know he's got first place uh
other than that we can start from the
bottom and work our way up to the top
Armin mccallion uh is sitting there with
one and a half points auction Chandra
two and a half Brandon Jacobson with
three and a half Christian Carrillo who
still is playing also tiker and
hartunian are still kind of in that
bottom middle area yeah uh they're still
playing so they might be able to get
more points but in this middle section
with Five Points we got regularly Cantor
Christopher you Dennis contract but our
second place winner is ronak sodwani
excellent very solid tournament and I
think he guaranteed it yeah already so
tigran haruting in unlikely case if he
wins
catch up but yeah but the position he's
dead lost in fact yeah absolutely and
one more congratulations to Alex
Linderman the winner of the B group in
this year's fall chess classic again
congratulations to Alex Linderman and in
the a group starting at the bottom we
have Sergey Ganguly who is still playing
a game Nicholas theodoro is tied for
eighth place with ilionic nijan amsov
tied with sixth place with Gregory
o'parin uh Armin harkobian and tied for
fourth place with Hans who is still
pending and is likely to get at least
half a point other than that we also
have third place Von Nguyen second place
visit Gujarati in first place
our back-to-back winner of the Classic
Series so a huge congratulations to both
of our winners
yeah that that was that was an
impressive performance from you yes
right if you ask me absolutely and if
you guys do want to keep following the
following the chest.org but this is
actually our last tournament for the
entire year uh this is it we're the very
very final ones so thank you so much to
everybody that's been watching everybody
on Twitch everybody on YouTube it's been
an absolutely wonderful uh time with you
guys spending it watching all of these
games and I hope that you guys have a
very happy holiday mural any last words
uh any lost words well to be perfectly
honest like a little bit of personal I
really enjoyed it back then in like when
I used to commentate for Saint Lucia's
club 2017-18 and then all this you know
crazy pandemic started and so on so I
was really happy to be back this July
and and this visit as well so thanks
very much guys for having me here
hopefully well was
if not say if I didn't bring any common
sense but at least hopefully in
entertainment
wonderful a true honor to sit here next
to you Miro it's been an absolutely
delightful time and thank you again to
everybody that has made this possible
and we will see you guys again next year
okay
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited